et alors là en revanche là ça me fait
pas rire du tout et vous savez à quel
point il était mais absolument énerver
un peu plus sur ce sujet ça m'a révolté
et vous aussi
on va aller à bobigny les habitants d'un
immeuble sont privés d'ascenseur depuis
quatre ans à la suite d'une panne
les journalistes du 12/13 nationale se
sont rendus sur place dans ce petit
immeuble de quatre étages
l'ascenseur est en panne depuis 2014
la copropriété a décidé de ne pas
réparer l'ascenseur suite à de très
nombreuses et très régulière
dégradations volontaires
nancy a dû venir s'installer chez sa
mère qui souffre d'une insuffisance
rénale et a besoin pour chaque
déplacement de se faire accompagner le
fondateur et l'avocat du collectif plus
sans ascenseur viennent aujourd'hui lui
présenter la mise en demeure du bailleur
à opérer les réparations le bailleur
assure vouloir trouver rapidement une
solution pour nelly pour l'heure
toujours rien concernant l'ascenseur
alors moi j'avoue je vous avoue que je
suis mais exaspéré par cette information
et un ascenseur qui tombe en panne en
moyenne trois fois par an l'entretien
coûte 50 centimes par jour par
appartement c'est l'estimation moyenne
ça franchement il s'agit d'un bailleur
social dans le reportage on voit une
dame qui est bloqué chez elle sa fille
est obligée d'en ménager
parce que sinon elle n'aurait pas les
moyens de demain de vivre parce que
cette femme a perdu la vue à des
difficultés pour se mouvoir et donc pour
sortir par cet escalier extérieur
extrêmement dangereux si sa fille
n'était pas là elle serait coupée du
monde et je trouve ça dingue je commence
à monter en pression à dans l'air qu'est
ce que vous en pensez top 6 me ouais ça
je le vois alors je suis beaucoup de
visites à domicile et je meurs je me
déplace le tabac en seine saint denis et
je vois que ça se passe globalement en
banlieue dans les grandes villes
globalement même si à des pannes
j'ai quand même le sentiment qu'on prend
un peu plus loin des ascenseurs quand il
tombe en plein dans la tendance à les
réparer un peu plus vite et j'entends
souvent dire à me regarder les habitants
en banlieue c'est eux qui cassent
l'ascenseur on n'a qu'à les laisser un
finalement il ya des casseurs et à de la
racaille laisser monter c'est ce que
répond le bailleur social en
l'occurrence samedi à grenade est
tellement facile
finalement on peut rien faire et dr on
assigne à résidence des personnes des
personnes malades et éventuellement les
dégradations d entrain exactement parce
que finalement c'est comme lorsqu'il ya
du deal les dans les cités ou peu
importe les premières des victimes c'est
les habitants merci là les premières
victimes c'est les locataires
donc on se rend compte que pas grand
chose et fait que c'est toujours chez
les plus pauvres que ça se passe
on fait pas grand chose alors qu'ils
payent c'est pas gratuit il est chargé
et j'ai vu une patiente comme ça qu'il
restait deux ans une personne âgée sa
seule maladie c'est d'abord un
déambulateur l'ascenseur ne marche pas
deux ans qu'elle ne sort pas de chez
elle parce que la façon de fonctionner
sans corde mais c'est fou et damien
alors j'étais en train de dire à 10 me
c'est voilà c'est parce que le bailleur
dit il ya eu des dégradations
donc maintenant on arrête allez on
arrête dehors de d'arranger d'arranger
cet ascenseur de le réparer cet
ascenseur et vous aviez l'air de dire
bah oui et on attend trop mal c'est vrai
que ces locataires payent un loyer et
des charges de copropriété du coup c'est
normal que les ascenseurs fonctionnent
ce n'est pas normal je la kiffe pendant
aussi longtemps réfère néanmoins c'est
vrai que malheureusement si ces pannes
ont lieu c'est aussi parce qu'il ya des
incivilités parce qu'elle du vol de
matériel et c'est pas parce que c'est un
ou deux qui dégradent que tout
l'immeuble va devoir suivre mais on y
compris là il est les personnes n'ayant
d'accord mais c'est comme très souvent
pour une minorité d'imbéciles c'est la
majorité qui trinquent et bien c'est
encore le cas et c'est vrai que c'est
triste que effectivement les bailleurs
ne puisse pas suivre
mais si effectivement il ya juste deux
zigotos qui derrière vont tout dégradé
mais malheureusement c'est le cas voilà
vous dit après tout ils ont raison les
bailleurs le bailleur en l'opa disons
qu'en tout cas je pense qu'ils se
servent de cet argument pour ensuite
retardé les travaux ce qui est
effectivement scandaleux dans ce cas là
mais en allemagne on si effectivement le
fait c'est que ses défenses immunitaires
moment donné c'est aussi normal dont
quatre ans ces maisons sont privés
notamment des jantes à mobilité réduite
qui peuvent pas sortir de chez eux ne
fait pas le seul argument souvent on
peut avoir des concurrents seront
communiqués des pannes dues à la panne
est la pièce elle arrive dans six mois
en six mois alors qu'ailleurs a pu venir
en trois super la commande et en
allemagne comme si on avait été sur la
lune à les récupérer
il faut qu'on arrête de dernière jimmy
c'est trop facile tu peux pas dire ça il
ya 550 pile l'ascenseur en france c'est
un moment donné à chaque fois il fallait
réparer la panne dans la seconde ce
serait très compliqué
carole et les médias la seconde il ya
quatre ans damien je comprends pas
comment tu peux systématiquement
défendre l'indéfendable c'est impossible
mais moi je suggère à ces gens non
seulement d'arrêter payer les charges
c'est quand même la base je dire quand
le truc n'est pas respectée et qu'il se
et qu'il ce qu'ils créent sont montés en
lan en colère sur un sexisme et il y en
a très peu qui sont de cet immeuble 1,5
en fait les gens subissent cette
situation on arrête de payer le loyer de
toute façon c'est la seule c'est le seul
levier qui fera bouger les choses donc
il faut vraiment qu'ils se mettent
requis et c'est incroyable c'est votre
vie mais de se mettre hors la loi pour
que la loi soit respectée et qu'on
épuise lit dans un groupe d'essen enfin
que et que les celles qui agissent en
finale au final ce sont les gens
justement qui viennent des banlieues il
ya un collectif qui a été créé qui
s'appelle plus sans ascenseur dont le
président est jean marc mormeck donc
l'ancien boxeur qui interviennent un
petit peu partout en banlieue pour venir
aider ces gens parce qu'il faut rappeler
aussi un truc et que tu oublie de
préciser c'est que c'est dans des tours
qui font de disques a renoncé à le faire
faillite et donc ils n'ont pas le choix
du tout moi j'habite à paris la dernière
fois on s'est retrouvé coincé dans
l'ascenseur en 45 minutes y avait
quelqu'un ne vais pas me faire croire
qu'ils peuvent pas faire la même chose
dans les banlieues on n'était pas normal